president salivating Provost Pollock
Dean Cooley Dean Gendler secretary golf
crews chaplain Coogler residential
college leaders honored guests and lest
we forget women and men of the class of
20 20 good morning and welfare
I want to extend my thank my welcome to
the parents and grandparents siblings
aunts and uncles who are with us today
as I welcome you I also want to
acknowledge your hard work and
sacrifices without you those of us on
stage and our colleagues throughout the
campus the librarians dining hall
workers professors custodians
groundskeepers coaches lecturers
religious leaders tutors administrative
assistants without you we would not have
the honor of guiding these young adults
our newest galleys through their
undergraduate years thank you for
trusting us with this duty as for you
class of twenty twenty I would like to
start things off by giving you your
first homework assignment what I want
you to do today is to take a quiet
moment to acknowledge your privileges
and your blessings and be sure to thank
someone who was not here for his or her
commitment to your success you have all
been blessed numerous times over with
remarkable abilities you might excel at
interpreting or running or coding you
might have a gift to conjugate or
titrate or swim maybe you sing or debate
I'm also guessing that more than a few
of you are level 5 or higher in Pokemon
go and have already discovered that this
very place where you're sitting this
August Hall is a massive pokemon gem
that aside these blessings brought you
here but only in part what you also have
to realize is how others beyond your
family had a role in your success I'm
sure that with little effort you can all
make a long list of people who deserve
some recognition and appreciation
neighbors best friends calculus teachers
guidance counselors cafeteria workers
chess club instructors boss's ear book
advisors principles on this special day
that is all about you do the proper and
generous thing and make someone else's
day special by thanking them in writing
as you count and share your blessings
reflect for a moment on who you are and
how far you have travelled to get here
you hail from small towns and remote
places and high rises in mega cities you
have spent endless hours on the family
farm helped your parents in the family
restaurant and volunteered at social
service agencies trying to help families
and dire straits you are from public
schools mostly parochial schools and
private schools you're from every state
in the United States and from 50 other
countries you're from Potomac Scarsdale
cape town fayetteville coral gables
waban singapore caramel Guilford
branford New Haven and too many other
places to mention you have come from
everywhere and you bring with you your
own stories but now you are here what
are you supposed to do now you might be
asking yourself who are you to become
ultimately you're the only ones who are
going to be able to answer these
questions but you're also going to have
a lot of help along the way from the
people you're going to meet over the
next four years including me let me
start by telling you a story that speaks
to this moment a few years ago my family
loaded the car and drove up to Maine we
were taking our daughter to her first
sleepaway camp and figured we would turn
the first part of our trip into a
vacation my wife booked a hotel for us
in Portsmouth New Hampshire a beautiful
coastal town known for its fourth of
July fireworks
we plan to get there early so that we
could see them then continue on our way
the next day after we checked into the
hotel we set out on foot and soon found
ourselves at strawberry Bank museum a 10
acre site that recounts over 300 years
of American history at strawberry Bank
visitors stroll around painstakingly
recreated gardens and houses and get to
speak to costumed role players as a
historian of the United States who
specializes in the african-american
experience these kinds of places usually
give me pause as they tend toward
oversimplified narratives of this
nation's rich and complex past
thankfully and to its credit strawberry
bank did not hide from the challenges of
its particular past but this is not
actually why I share the story a mention
strawberry bank because as fate would
have it I had come on a day when the
museum was hosting a naturalization
ceremony on that day the fourth of July
the anniversary of this country's
Declaration of Independence a few
hundred people from around the world
from all different life circumstances
have gathered on that site to present
the requisite paperwork to declare their
allegiance to this country and to become
legal citizens the cumulative and
completely unexpected significance of
this moment caught me off guard and when
the magistrate declared on Moss that the
assembled were now citizens tears roll
down my cheeks sure my emotions were
fueled by romantic patriotism a
naturalization ceremony on july 4th at a
living history museum that tells an
uplifting story of a colonial past i
mean really but i was mainly moved by
the overarching narrative so many
strangers had come to this place the
United States New Hampshire Portsmouth
strawberry bank they had come to this
place believing in the possibilities
afforded by full citizenship they made a
collective leap of faith that they would
find through citizenship a place to
realize their ambitions for some this
meant access to certain jobs for others
this meant uniting a family for still
others this
finding refuge all I am confident
believe that they were ready to make
substantive contributions to their new
community now today I'm looking out at
you strangers who have come to this
place believing in the possibility
afforded by the full citizenship that
was bestowed on you last night when you
sign your registration forms I will not
claim to know all of your histories
before this moment but I do know that
you are here and I believe that you are
here because you have some sort of
vision of what possibilities will accrue
to you through your relationship to Yale
that is this day in four or five years
you'll be receiving a diploma from this
institution when the president confers
the degrees upon you he will also admit
you to the rights and responsibilities
that are associated with being a member
of the Yale alumni community but why
wait until that moment to talk about
your responsibilities as a Yale citizen
given that we are in the final months of
a tendentious presidential campaign and
given the local national and global
events that are testing us to our core I
feel it important to talk about your
responsibilities as citizens of this
community at the moment of your becoming
I want specifically to talk about your
responsibilities to each other I return
to who you are you have come from
everywhere and until yesterday most of
you were strangers to one another but
you are yay Lee's now you are now part
of a tradition that reaches back over
three centuries but this is a tradition
that is also about change for example if
you were to consider the entering yield
class from 75 years ago you would learn
that twenty-five percent of the class
came from five prep schools and within
that group almost half from Phillips
Academy
satta Phillips alum I'm hearing out
there um most undergraduates came from
five states the farthest away being Ohio
and when I say most I mean this
literally imagine the total number of
students from the rest of the country
thirty-two african-american students
were an extreme rarity in that general
era in fact there were none in that
class there was however one Filipino
every undergraduate of course was male
the Yale to which you belong the one
that I hope you have already started to
call your own looks different in the
most obvious ways yours is a more
complex scale and it is one that
presents you with challenges that your
predecessors could not then have
imagined this complexity however does
not free from a responsibility to
discover it is our expectation in fact
that you will impress the embrace the
challenge of so much difference riding
on what he called the encountered other
literary critic Derek attridge tells us
that when we meet a stranger the demand
for justice requires that we recognize a
fundamental humanity in that stranger
attridge argues that if we meet that
demand and respond to the other person
through openness we will ourselves
change and grow it is important to
realize that the stakes of these
exchanges are high at their best they
represent as Attridge tells us
opportunities for new ways of seeing the
world but these exchanges are also
filled with risk venturing into new
spaces and encountering the unknown
means exposing yourself to new ideas and
new ways of communicating the words we
use the way we use them the way we hear
them every action is stick with
potential as you take up and explore
your own new citizenship of this place
consider the risks that generations have
taken over time as they ventured toward
a new place and either literally or
figuratively learn to speak a new
language I will not claim to know the
histories of those people who gathered
on that fourth of July a few years ago
to become citizens but I know they took
risks to get to strawberry bank
you two have taken risks and now that
you are here we hope that you will
continue to do so by engaging the
differences all around you journey into
uncertainty and meet with excitement and
passion all that confounds you angers
you challenges you and enthralls you
come to these moments with integrity and
honesty and most of all dare to listen
to what you hear I said earlier that the
stakes are high I believe this to be the
case in large measure because we need
each other to make this whole thing work
we are as Gwendolyn Brooks rights we are
each other's harvest we are each other's
business we are each other's magnitude
and bond judge learn at hand wrote that
a college may gather together men of a
common tradition or may put its faith in
learning members of the class of 20 20
you are our newest yell citizens and you
come from many different traditions you
are on the verge of beginning and
education unlike any that you have had
before it will it will happen in the
classrooms to be sure but it will also
happen with every encounter you have
with every stranger you meet and with
every leap of faith you take in which
you declare this place has something for
you and that you have something for this
place this is what you will find as you
enter Yale and as you lay claim to your
status as citizen you are at the
threshold now poised I for one am eager
to discover what you will find dana
gioia poet laureate of california writes
about this moment this cusp in his poem
entrance i leave you with his words
whoever you are step out of doors
tonight out of the room that lets you
feel secure infinity is open to your
site whoever you are with eyes that have
forgotten how to see from viewing things
already too well known lift up into the
dark a huge black tree and put it in the
heavens tall alone and you have made the
world and all you see it ripens like the
words still in your mouth and when at
last you comprehend its truth then close
your eyes and gently set it free thank
you
you
you
good morning and welcome welcome to my
colleagues here on stage to the family
members who've joined us today and
especially to the Yale class of 20 20 20
20 20 20 is a term that inevitably
inevitably brings to mind perfect vision
perfect I say and now that all of you
are wearing 2020 as your class label in
Yale College I'm confident that your
intuition and your mental acuity will
develop here to an equivalent level of
strength the emissions Office assures me
that everything possible has been done
to guarantee this outcome nonetheless
I'd like to reflect on your first day of
school about what might impede your
insight and what might advance it in the
course of your education here for many
years I taught introductory psychology
to a large number of freshman in the
part of that course devoted to social
psychology I would ask my students to
consider what we know about helping
others in various kinds of social
situations specifically why is it that
we offer assistance or fail to offer
assistance in emergencies I would begin
with the tragic and well known case of
kitty Genovese a 29 year old woman who
lived in kew gardens queens and was
murdered there in 1964 her case received
enormous attention and commentary and
you have probably heard some version of
her story as reported in the New York
Times
38 individuals watched the murder from
their apartment windows but only one
called the police and by then it was too
late over the years I've described this
shocking incident many times so have
other social psychologists teaching
similar courses and so did the social
scientists who sought to explain how
witnesses could exhibit such callous
indifference to a horrific crime taking
place before their eyes here's the
trouble the standard account of the
kitty Genovese II case is wrong in some
of its crucial details Kitty's brother
Bill Jen avicii produced the film last
year maybe some of you have seen it
called the witness in it he documents
that some bystanders were not
indifferent one witness shouted out the
window at the attacker another witness
held Kitty in her arms as she died and
several called the police during the
attack so what does it mean that social
scientists have been retelling an
incorrect version of this story for over
50 years as a paradigmatic example of
extreme bystander indifference well
among other things it means that
inadvertently we have been perpetuating
what might rightly be called a false
narrative a version of events that while
partly true has been shaped in this case
by a newspaper report to elicit strong
negative emotions like anger like fear
like discussed as an investigator of
human emotions that's my area in
psychology I know that even the most
negative feelings can be important to
our survival anger effectively signals
that a goal is being blocked fear
motivate
caution and preparation disgusts
discussed moves us away from things that
can make us ill however sometimes our
friends family members politicians
advertisers pundits and others look to
manipulate our emotions for their own
purposes anger fear and disgust can be
highly effective ways to drive eyeballs
to websites consumers to products or
voters to the polls my sense is that we
are bombarded daily by false narratives
of various kinds and that they're doing
a great deal of damage in a national
election season you don't need to look
very hard to find them it's not my
purpose today to mock the biggest
whoppers or award Pinocchio's for the
biggest distortions rather I'm only
hoping to persuade you that advocates on
any side of a question can be tempted to
exaggerate or distort or neglect crucial
facts in ways that serve primarily to
fewer to fuel your anger your fear or
your disgust if I'm correct then an
important aspect of your education here
will be learning how to recognize and
address these kinds of accounts in the
course of that you should pay especially
close attention to the narratives that
seem to align best with your own beliefs
to the extent you hold strong political
or cultural or religious or economic
beliefs any beliefs you will simply be
like all the rest of us if you gravitate
toward explanations that seem to provide
confirmation for those beliefs or to
demonize those who hold different ones
all of us are strongly pre deposed
predisposed to accept accounts
that align with the opinions we already
hold and to ignore ignore or dismiss
those that do not social media the
blogosphere and the political process
are increasingly drenched with such
narratives in flaming our negative
emotions and presenting real barriers to
reasons investigation productive
exchanges between differing views and
the search for common ground on the most
challenging problems facing our global
societies so you are now embarking on an
ambitious and hopeful effort to
understand the world your place in it
and what you can contribute to forward
progress how can you address the
seductive power of false narratives
especially in a time when grave mistrust
on many sides seems to be fueling ever
more of them it will not surprise you
that I'm highly aware of false
narratives circulating about students
like yourselves and about higher
education in general I have a thick
shelf of Contemporary books in my office
assuring me that students at elite
universities are merely excellent sheep
that a liberal arts degree is a ticket
to unemployment that truly inspired and
courageously learners drop out of
college to found tech companies that
Millennials cannot make decisions
without consulting their parents that
college professors have uniformed
political views that students these days
are fragile fragile hothouse flowers
that is not possible to achieve an
inclusive campus culture without giving
up on free speech and that our colleges
and universities are cut off from
reality in response
I want to claim that your Yale education
will not only enlarge your imagination
advance your knowledge and propel your
career but also that it will be
absolutely critical to your capacity for
playing a positive leadership role in
these increasingly polarized and
fractious times in particular you're
about to be taught by outstanding
teachers and mentors whose lives and
careers constitute a powerful witness
for the value of a disciplined reasoned
and careful search for light and truth
what unites our faculty from engineering
to economics to English to environmental
studies is a stubborn skepticism about
narratives that oversimplify issues that
inflame the emotions that misdirect the
mind no one is free of biases of course
but as a community of scholars we
subscribe to the ideal of judicious
searching inquiry in the service of
reasoned discourse about the matters we
investigate and care about the most we
would be lost as academics without this
ideal and our global societies would be
lost if universities stop being places
defined by this ideal I could supply you
with a long list of the L faculty who
have spent decades of their lives in
laboratories in archives and libraries
and in field settings collecting
evidence to challenge some received
notion some distorted narrative or some
common wisdom that turned out to be
highly questionable here are some
examples
many people assume that our legal system
was built entirely on a secular
tradition but yells professor of
medieval history on ders win roth
counters the false narrative that
contemporary legal reasoning is a
radical departure from medieval canon
law by showing that in many ways it's
rooted in it important cosmologies of
past of the past depended on the
assumption that the planet Earth is
unique in the universe astronomy
professor Deborah Fisher has discovered
many worlds called exoplanets orbiting
around Suns in solar systems spread
throughout the galaxy medical
researchers assumed for many years that
gender has little to do with the
prevalence and course of most illnesses
and that the findings from studies with
men automatically generalize to women
Carolyn Missouri the director of the
Women's Health Research Center at Yale
has been investigating critical
differences that gender makes in a wide
range of biological systems and
translates those findings into new
health practices a few more most
classically trained economists have
modeled human decisions as the result of
careful calculations of costs and
benefits Nobel Prize winner Robert
Shiller has emerged at the forefront of
those who challenge the idea of rational
individuals and markets forcing major
revisions to the theory of human
behavior on which his field economics is
based when I was a graduate student in
psychology the dominant narrative held
that humans learn virtually everything
from experience but psychology professor
Karen Wynn has been teaching us that
human infants have surprising in
capacities five months olds appear able
to make rudimentary arithmetic
calculations and psychology professor
Laurie Santos the new head of Sullivan
college has been showing us that monkeys
too seemed pre-wired for such complex
states as resentment envy and cognitive
dissonance I'll close my list of
examples by referencing professor of
African American American Studies hazel
car be her first book called
reconstructing womanhood was an
exceptional exploration of the ways in
which nineteenth-century black women
writers in America confronted and
transformed the domestic and literary
ideals of womanhood in white society
professor karbi wrote a telling remark
in her forward to a book called
silencing the past highlighting the
power of challenging false or incomplete
narratives about the marginalized this
is her quote we learn how scanty
evidence can be repositioned to generate
new narratives how silences can be made
to speak for themselves people naturally
construct narratives to make sense of
their world I've been concerned to point
out that in times of great stress false
narratives may dominate the public mind
and public discourse in flaming negative
emotions and fanning discord in our
times especially a wide array of
instantaneous transmissions amplify such
narratives and as a result we sometimes
find that anger and fear and disgust can
blind us to the complexity of the world
and the responsibility to seek deeper
understandings of important issues one
point of view Yale education then is for
you to become a more careful and
critical thinker
to learn the difficult painstaking
skills you will need in order to
evaluate evidence to deliberate more
broadly and more carefully and to arrive
at your own conclusions more
particularly the L is a place for you to
learn how and why to gravitate toward
people who view things differently than
you do who will test your most strongly
held assumptions it is also a place to
learn why it takes extraordinary
discipline courage and persistence often
over a lifetime to construct new
foundations for tackling the most
intractable and challenging questions of
our time you've come to a place where
civil disagreements and deep rethinking
are the heart and soul of the enterprise
where we prize exceptional diversity of
views alongside the greatest possible
freedom of expression so I trust that
you will begin immediately to seek out
what is best about this place the
faculty and staff and peers who will
both inspire you and prepare you to
become the investigators the visionaries
and the leaders the world so sorely
needs none of us here can hope for a
better world or even for a more
inclusive and exhilarating learning
community at Yale unless we succeed at
this mission you are in fact what gives
us hope you are in fact why we became
educators you are why we are here
welcome to Yale
you
Oh
my beloved Yale family as we ready
ourselves to step out onto new ground in
this daunting yet inspiring liminal
space of the unknown next we begin a
poignant turn of goodbyes and hellos
that invite laughter tears challenge
choice discovery and pride let us go
forth with deep trust in certain
knowledge that every one of us is
welcome here that love surrounds us that
beauty can surprise us and that light
and truth awaits us on this day and each
day forward may all that is holy shine
upon us and tenderly bless our every
breath may we go in Shalom in Shanti may
we go in peace let us begin
you